hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play slender
flashlight now it's been a while since I
played any sort of slender game let
alone one that's different from the
original slender games but this one
looked like it actually had a lot of
work put into it and was really well
done so I wanted to give it a try so
here we go and just judging by like the
title music that's actually pretty cool
I don't know if that's an original score
but at least it's this whole sequence is
well made okay and turn oh I actually
have to click it none okay there we go
alright so we're in the game and right
off the bat I can tell that everything
looks like a shade of blue and mauve and
it seems to have some sort of filter on
it to make it look like I'm actually
looking through a camera okay so I'm in
a house this I can deduce a house made
of wood
hmmm how strange this is so peculiar
alright so since I am in a house I'm
wondering if there's anything any earth
I don't know if there are random spawn
points or if this is where I'm always
gonna spawn in now just right off the
bat I can sort of tell that this is
actually pretty well made I'm kind of
impressed it's not the same unity engine
trees that you see in all the other
games and it's actually got some style
to it which is what I like to see you
know in an indie game like take
something and make your own style at it
okay I got the first page and the thumpy
thump is back the good old thumpy thump
oh this is actually pretty nice I'm
fairly impressed by this
okay so tromping through the woods and
the other slender games that took place
in the woods
usually hi there you had tentacles hi
there well welcome to the game you're
here a bit early don't you think okay so
[ __ ] men with their
in front of what I glimpsed his model
looks pretty good he actually had
tentacles and he was kind of really
really really tall like really tall hmm
this might actually be one of the better
slender games
it wasn't very impactful when he
appeared but still that's not bad okay
hi
I saw that I saw you there I think I saw
you there anyway it was either that or a
tree
okay now also I have to say that the
music is pretty intense that what is
that what is that what is that I found a
flashlight and a vial of blood why why
is this here is there a page around here
are you pointing towards that tree so a
page on the tree no I would have guessed
that oh man this is weird why is there a
flashlight here
let's do confusing okay so anyway it's
not pointing towards a paint I would
think that would be a page renders it's
got to be right I'm just being stupid
about it Emma no no there's not a page
here okay so let's just follow it
backwards and see if there's a page over
here
I know there's probably one page hidden
on that music is like serious business
I've only gotten one page mr. music you
can whoa hi hi how's it going there
wow I'm back at the oh I just went in a
big circle thank you very much I'll go
this way now all right so this is
actually pretty impressive right now I'm
more interested than the in the
atmosphere than slender himself slender
himself is not that scary to me this
atmosphere is fantastic oh hello what is
that what did I find
some sort of dilapidated barn let's see
if we can go in
seriously that means like I said it
chills up my spine that is amazing oh hi
oh well you're in there okay
well I just won't look at you can you
kill me I have no idea are you still
there oh hello this guy's beheaded and
there's a page give me the page there we
go I got two pages now what's gonna
happen whole world is gonna cave in on
itself after two pages hi where where I
don't see what happened did something
happen do something scary happen well
darn it I missed it oh well wow I guess
I'll just keep walking Susie I think I
hear the slender sees you noise but it's
really not all that impactful New Jersey
the music is just way too much right off
in the beginning I mean it's really cool
don't get me wrong it's really cool
I don't know I can't sprint so I can't
go any faster than just and I haven't
seen a what I would call a path yet hi
Hisle Andy how you doing
oh I see my sanity bar at the bottom or
meter at the bottom goes way down real
quick if slender appears in front of me
it's cut oh hi
hey hi hi how's it going you're not
scary but hi I think a lot of work needs
to be done on the son of man mechanics
actually you know playing through this
game this could be an amazing horror
game of something that's not slender you
know you could make something original
here because the atmosphere is
phenomenal I love it I love this
atmosphere but Slenderman I don't know
if it's just overexposure or somewhat
wave he vanished he was there but he
vanished oh now my sanity's Perot there
goes okay yeah I mean a Slenderman right
now is not that scary I don't know if
it's overexposure to Slenderman or just
the mechanics in this game don't allow
to be that scary but I mean seriously
you could have a great horror game on
your hands here if you just picked
another avenue this could be fantastic
tarah probably being too mean I mean he
intentionally tried to make a Slenderman
game and I mean there's a lot of
Slenderman games and this one does stand
out its own way except for Slenderman
that's all I'm trying to say everything
else is great except this Slenderman
this reminds me when I was playing
scp-432 oh hello what is this no how did
I go in a circle okay that's cool the
game is messin with me because that's
the second time I've gone in a circle
and I swear I have it if this game is
messing with me that would be way
impressive I would be very impressed or
maybe the way Slenderman is set up is
that he appears so that it tried it
drives me drives me in a circle I don't
know if there's some ulterior mechanic
going on I would be very impressed by
Brides being stupid and running in
circles that's probably what I'm doing
unless that was a different barn I don't
think it was was it whatever man I have
no idea
I haven't even found an outskirt to the
level of no idea what's going on I've
only got two pages this place must be
huge hi how you doing you look really
good Slendy have you lost weight
have you gotten taller are your
tentacles bigger that's what she said
dung where oh there okay
um yeah I'm just lost in the woods here
I haven't seen a landmark in a while and
there's no path hi how you doing how you
doing slender man you're not a very big
threat to me either because I don't
think you chased me like in some of the
more horrific Slender games that I
played
cuz that's what he's supposed to do or I
don't know if that's what he's supposed
to do but it was definitely more
clarifying and the other ones okay come
on I really would like a landmark at
some point hi Slendy how you doing oh
you almost got me there my slender meter
my slender meter almost dropped to zero
things like it's taking longer for my
sanity to go back up after seeing them
that's something but for now I'm just
wandering straight through the woods
I love
yeah yeah okay sorry I'm just gotta get
I'm getting bored and I don't know what
to do I'm just I have no idea what to do
it
I found a wall it's just a sheer
mountain they go straight up well good
for me good for me
I probably wasn't supposed to walk this
far out this way okay yeah I think I'm
done
I have no idea what to do I have no idea
what to do
ah where's Lenny man kill me just get it
over with
just kill me killing in the torment I've
gotten out of his range he's not even
gonna come out this far he heard what I
said about him and he was insulted so
now he's going into hiding can I die
dying would I find another out here
where is he where I don't see him where
is he I heard the noise I heard hot are
you hiding from me now flooded man do
you know either black by that words the
blacksmith where's the blacksmith of you
in the page at the blacksmith
I'm scarier than you Slendy man ah okay
alright enough of that let me just take
in the atmosphere for a little bit mmm I
can smell these trees oh look at the
lost foliage on the ground yeah okay I'm
I've now I've now run out of my bag of
jokes uh-huh ah markiplier is so funny
alright look at him make random noises
and grunt and make funny faces
yeah it's comedy gold right there I just
want him to kill me and this and this so
I can stop being making an ass out of
myself there hi
you're looking really good Dada okay now
there we go alright so mechanics-wise
there's a lot of problems
atmospheric wise that was fantastic like
amazing
top-notch it's just Slenderman himself
was not threatening at all whatsoever he
was so easy to avoid and even if he was
right next to you it wasn't a threat and
actually now that I got a closer look at
him I'm wondering if that is the same
model used from slender haunt because if
it is that wouldn't be too cool but
there's a lot of potential here and this
is an early alpha so don't judge it too
harshly like I did and make random
noises make random noises while you play
if you want to be a good let's player
make random noises scream whenever you
can and make funny faces and you'll be
YouTube famous in no time so anyway
professional advice from markiplier so
there's a lot of potential year just
needs it quite a bit of work and you
know you could go in a whole different
direction from slender and you'd have a
great horror game on your hands so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see
in the next video under none Dharma by
nerd under
none undone oh it's gone dun dun dun da
da na na na na na na na na na Nana na na
na na na